hello and welcome to med simplified in
this video we will talk about five of
the best shampoos that you can use if
you are suffering from hair loss
hair loss is also known as alopecia in
dermatology
and it is a very very common problem
affecting millions of people across the
globe
hair loss can occur due to a variety of
reasons and in our previous videos we
have discussed in detail about why hair
fall occurs and the lifestyle changes
you can do to prevent hair loss so make
sure to watch that video first
hair loss of 100 hairs per day is normal
but it is very difficult to guess when
this limit of 100 hairs is crossed
here are some warning signs that you
should keep in mind if you are having
excessive hair loss
if you notice a bunch of hair while
combing or shampooing your hair
if you find hair almost every day on
your pillow
beddings or floor if your hair is
getting thinner and smaller
if you can see the bald scalp through
your shrinking mane
in case of males a receding of the
frontal hairline can be seen as
broadening of the forehead
in females you may notice a widening of
central parting and reduction in the
volume of the ponytail
you can also do a simple hair pull test
pull a bunch of approximately 100 hairs
from root to tip using moderate pressure
if you notice
more than 6 hairs then it is an
indicator that you are having
active hair fall regardless of the
reasons you can always use
a good anti-hair fall shampoo that
strengthens the hair and the hair
follicles
so you can control the rate of hair loss
let's start with the number one shampoo
that we have on our list which is the
kerastase tensorfeek
bain densai shampoo this anti-hair fall
shampoo from kerastase contains the
combination of stemoxedine and
hyaluronic acid
simoccidine is a topical hair loss
solution that was patented in 2012 by
the popular cosmetic brand
l'oreal it is a prolel 4 hydroxylase
inhibitor
also known as p4h enzyme inhibitor
previously l'oreal had an active
ingredient called
amin excel in their hair growth products
but eventually amin excel was replaced
by stem oxidine in
all of their products eventually
becoming the standard
now the researchers claim that by
inhibiting p4h enzyme
streamoxidine is able to stimulate new
stem cells in our hair follicles
therefore creating longer and denser
hair
hyaluronic acid will prevent a dry scalp
and hair from thinning and eventually
falling out
topical hyaluronic acid helps to lock in
water into the hair shaft
which provides hydration and moisture
for the hair that's thin
flat or even damaged it is a gentle
shampoo that will improve the density
and help to build hair strength i've
heard positive feedbacks from almost all
of my patients to whom i have
recommended this shampoo
number two indulika anti-hair fall
shampoo
the brand indulika started its venture
with hair oil
with time the hair oil became pretty
popular and recently indulika expanded
its hair care line by introducing their
anti-hair fall shampoo to the market
this shampoo contains ayurvedic
ingredients that help to control hair
fall
the most important ayurvedic component
of this shampoo is bhringraj
prangraj or bhringa is one of the oldest
remedies to treat hair problems
since ancient times this herb has been
used to treat premature grain
hair fall problems dandruff problems and
other hair related problems
for hair regrowth it is one of the most
trusted ingredients
it also contains amla which is full of
vitamin c
it helps to treat hair loss problems and
it is also a good solution for premature
graying
dandruff problems etc to maintain the
luster of hair amla is pretty popular
too
it contains tulsi also which helps in
controlling itching and dandruff
now this shampoo also contains henna
which helps to maintain ph balance for
the scalp
and also promotes hair growth and
conditions the hair
it also contains rosemary and shikakai
which are very good herbs for hair
growth
number three sane botanica biotin and
collagen
anti-hair fall shampoo this anti-airfall
shampoo
is sulfate free shampoo worth buying for
dry and damaged hair
prone to dandruff thinning and hair loss
it has vitamin b7
also known as biotin hydrolyzed collagen
oat
aloe vera sunflower oil avocado oil and
jojoba oil
that can nourish dry and damaged hair
biotin is also known as vitamin b7
and is found in few foods and nuts it
helps to improve hair texture and makes
them look healthier and fuller
it controls hair fall and helps in new
hair growth
number four tresemme hair fall defense
shampoo
this shampoo is known for its advanced
hair fall defense keratin technology
which is especially formulated for
damage and breakage prone hair
keratin is the main ingredient in the
outer layer of our hair
which is known for smoothing
straightening and controlling frizzy
hair
it helps to reinforce your hair strength
and prevents hair fall due to breakage
after hearing a positive review from
many people i can say that it does
control hair fall but
with regular usage it also works great
in eliminating frizz and hair remains
tangle free even without using a
conditioner
number five m caffeine green tea
hair fall control shampoo
green tea is considered to be good for
hair and this anti-hair fall shampoo
combines the goodness of green tea to
gently remove the toxins and debris from
hair
and improves the hair texture green tea
in this shampoo has antioxidant
properties
which fight the buildup of toxins due to
pollution and urban lifestyle
these antioxidants eliminate free
radicals and also prevent
sun damage caused by uv rays caffeine
and vitamin e in this shampoo also act
as
antioxidants to remove free radical
damage it also contains argon and olive
oils
which are very good for weak hair
you can find all the links to these
shampoos in the description box down
below
write down in the comments below that
which shampoo according to you has
worked
best for hair fall for you till now
thank you so much for watching and see
you in the next video